three-point field goal klay Thompson
timeout Bulls Thompson oh and another
one he's wide open again and there he is
again
Durant back to green rolling to the
corner Blake Thompson got a steal I
think that's it's unselfish as you can
catch remember to yield they played last
night yeah and they look fresh night to
get Boyd had a layup back out to greens
and Thompson corner jumper for did you
did you see
draymond Green good shot to get a great
shot here he is he's gonna have it right
here and then watch he's gonna wait and
look at the screen by curry to get him
open and then just recognizing who's got
the hot ain't were 17 in the game
[Music]
Thompson Rises scholars saying is time
they've got 20 seconds to run always
four seconds off the clock play Thompson
again see what again it used the third
period klay Thompson continuing to range
shots on the Bulls crowd of defenders
curry shoveled the Thompson firing what
if he said shut up here thought there's
no kryptonite here no kryptonite here is
that kryptonite and curry curry screens
for Thompson again he fires again
good day y'all just deliver only ya
trying to give this good these get here
52 points timeout pulls back with 453
left and the third
[Music]